merci est battu mais j'avais je le
connais même pas les salaires de choses
se calment le magazine télé 2 semaines
qui en ce moment au kiosque a révélé
lors d'une grande enquête les salaires
bruts des présentateurs chroniqueurs et
comédien à la télé on va vous révéler
les chiffres il ya une grosse partie de
l' enquête qui porte sur les
chroniqueurs de tpm paix et de balances
ton post on vous a fait un petit récap
et vous allez voir certaines pour
assouvir notre curiosité télé 2 semaines
a publié une enquête sur le salaire des
stars de la télé on y découvre par
exemple que l'animatrice de tf1 karine
ferri en poche 1500 euros par tirage du
loto incroyable à cyril féraud quant à
lui serait payé 650 euros par numéro de
slam sur france 3 enfin je trouve ça
génial
olivier minne animateur star de france 2
gagnerait 2000 euros par émission
présentée un tarif proche de celui d'un
certain benjamin castaldi qui
empocherait jusqu'à 4000 euros par prime
animé sur ces huit dans la liste des
chroniqueurs toujours on apprend qu'eric
naulleau toucherait 1800 euros par
prestation dans balances ton post quant
à valérie benaïm elle serait rémunéré
1200 euros par émission en moyenne un
chroniqueur de tpm paix empocherait
entre 150 et 1500 euros paraît ainsi on
a vu tout on a vu tous les salaires ce
que ça paie ou mater les enquêtes sur
les salaires est ce que ça vous
intéresse ce sont les salaires des
comédiens des chroniqueurs alors on a vu
ils disent aussi dont enquête je vous
dis le journaliste ne révèle pas le
salaire il a dit je ne révèle pas le
salaire d'arthur de nagui ni de cyril
hanouna
car difficile à établir avec avec
précision voilà donc voilà il n'y pas
voilà donc le jeu dit voilà il est donc
valérie benaïm genre ils vous diront
certains mais je vais me rends compte
surtout que benjamin quatre fois plus
payer que moi 50 euros mais celle
d'origine quand même izumi et jongleurs
ils ont mis une fourchette très très
l'argent alors vous j'adore moi excusez
moi et benjamin castaldi qui n'a
d'ailleurs pas eu le courage de venir
aujourd'hui il gagne 4000 euros par
prime c'est ok la vraie parce qu'il a
pris là jamais confirmé attendait masse
et il va nous le dire
le prague sur les
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
j'espère à rembourser malo alors on
rigole et ce sont des sommes
astronomiques 1 on va pas se mentir
c'est vrai voilà et il faut savoir
benjamin castaldi vous savez que quand
ils pouvaient toucher pour une saison de
loft story époque il touché 600 mille
euros pour la saison
bon c'est comme les joueurs de foot faut
voir combien ça rapporte c'est la loi de
la il faut voir aussi que les carrières
ses murs et les sponsors et les
samoussas vous choque sous le nom de
gros salaires ou pas franchement non pas
du tout parce que je sais que le travail
que sa demande derrière parce qu'il ya
plein de gens n'y a plein de français
qui travaillent très dur qui ont des
travail la pénibilité très très forte et
qui se doit les six qui se disent
mine de rien nous on travaille on se
réveille le matin à 6 heures on se
couche le soir on est fracassée à la
balade
on ne rentre le soir à 19h ondes et
fracasse mine de rien on gagne ça vaut
pour par mois et canton c'est vrai que
moi oui mais lui gagne 4000 euros mais
de combien de temps il travaille pas
nous on est des acteurs de ya des
moments où pendant six sept voire huit
mois on travaille pas du tout et et on
gagne des 10000 sur un coût mais il faut
foncer pouvoir manger pendant des mois
je veux que vous connaissez bien moi
c'est là c'est pas que j'aime la dalle
ça fait longtemps que tu vas monter sur
scène dès que j'ai mis de côté on m'a
pris non mais c'est pareil ça devrait
pas trop non mais c'est la dernière fois
que suis monté sur scène j'avais presque
quoi un an
d'accord bah comment tu fais à côté
ouais bien sûr oui bon c'est vrai que
ces décès après après c'est vrai que je
vous vois que vous connaissez mal les
l'équipe de touche pas à mon poste
si vous aviez quand il travaille
travaille je préfère vous le dire et
puis pour être honnête conduit castany
guen quatre mines et je crois que c'est
sur facture c'est exactement à l'air
exactement pareil cadeau ils viennent
comme le papa à peu près voilà ça fait à
peu près lui voilà 1500 euros ce qui est
quand même énorme
et moi je moi je moi je mal parce que
voilà wallace de serre des autres ça
m'intéresse donc ça ne me choque pas
qu'on me demande mon salaire à moi
schultz à onet martin levac salaires
dans touche pas à mon pote quelque 600
700 euros par émission voila voila merci
battu que j'avais je le sais je connais
même pas les salaires de choc à moins
que jean michel
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
la prime dans sur plaisance et je sais j
que vous avez privilégié c'est sa part
émission vous happer voulait les
enquêtes sur les salaires oui joseph je
m'en fous complètement mais tout ça on
en parle des salaires depuis la jean luc
delarue avec le scandalise assure le
producteur
alors faut dire aussi que c'est l'arbre
qui cache la forêt parce qu'il ya
beaucoup de personnes qui sont dans
l'audiovisuel qui n'ont pas l'ombre
exacte de ce qui est dit là et en plus
il ya une grande différence aussi avec
la presse écrite et en presse écrite
souvent des gens naissent de presse
écrite qu'ils sortent ces infos parce
que ça n'a rien à voir non plus avec les
mêmes tarifs à presse écrite a là rien à
bercy jacky mois jacques est ce que toi
tu étais petit ça t'intéresse les
salaires tu t'es tu crois qu'il est dans
la tête depuis longtemps tu reconnais
voilà c'était cdc les fourchettes que du
fond tout ça normal tu trouves ça et tu
mets même les gens ma télé réalité 2
voilà là tu es là tu l'essor fait
impression toi